yo buu lakehead podcast man this kid
right here
he got a big song you know you might
know him ddg cat man
hey how how good does it feel to like uh
finally have a song where like
it's you know you've you've been making
so much music for so long and like
you got a record just really got legs
like it's
feeling like a hit man yeah this feels
like a hit
i mean i gotta go record off this r b
song i made
right right right and that that was your
first plaque i saw you guys post about
that earlier this year
yeah so but that took a little minute
but this
this one was quick because it's already
gold right this is about gold yeah it's
already gold
i just didn't get the um the plaque yeah
the plaque but
you gotta wait till it just goes
platinum it's it's on its way yeah i
want the platinum
to go cool but i already got it now yeah
congrats man like i know you put the
record out and then it started to kind
of take off and you put blueface on the
remix like when you did the record did
you like have any idea that
this was the one for you you like you
knew it off the rip
cause it was just catchy like it was
ella catchy i had no writers
i wrote everything myself i was just in
the
booth freestyling yeah you know what i
want to give you that prop
because a lot of people who you know
might be from your background like use a
lot of writers and
you i mean i've seen you in the studio
you write all your own [ __ ]
yeah i truly like i tried to use writers
but i don't really
it's not me you know what i mean it's
like i feel like i'm
a way better writer myself you know what
i mean i know what i went through
plus you believe in it yeah it's your
story yeah i know how i want to word it
i know how i want to
project it you know what i mean so i
feel like i'm just
getting better and better 100 man um now
you've had a crazy year in the sense
that uh first of all
you and and ruby rose had a pretty wild
public relationship
yeah yeah you know i'm assuming that's
over
that's over with yeah how uh you know
how was it
being in a public relationship like that
where
you know whenever it just seemed like
things you know sometimes got a little
sloppy on the internet and then you know
people coming up with assumptions about
your life and
yeah how was that i mean it's just it's
annoying
to be honest public relationships are
very hard
it's not as easy as people think for
everybody to have opinions on it
so it's like you know it's stressful you
got millions of people in your business
facts you know what i mean it's like you
can't do you can't have a private
relationship you know well especially
both of you guys are
public figures that's what i'm saying so
it's like you know we make money off the
internet
what do you think went wrong uh with
your with with you guys in particular
what you tried to get what type of title
you trying to get in this video i don't
know man
you're the youtube guy uh
i don't know you know was it just like
you think it was like some of the public
pressure or just you know
yeah no we we still cool though you guys
are still cool yeah
it's just you know stuff happens you
know relationships
go on and off you know you get into
arguments and then you push
bump heads did she start her only fans
while she was with you
yeah i haven't subscribed so i don't
know what kind of content's on it right
and i know you were one of the first
celebrities i remember seeing star only
fans where you were like yo if you want
some
game subscribe to my only fans because i
got some game for you yeah
about you know which i thought was dope
yeah and i want to get into some of that
game but
but like is that uh you know
being in a relationship and then the
girl gets the olding fans is that you
know is that a
weird conversation or no i think every
girl in the world
should have only fans every girl in the
world should have only fans it's the
easiest money in the world
i don't know why i'm just i'm just
saying that's just how i feel though you
know what i mean i
don't it doesn't bother me at all i'm
like [ __ ] get your money you know
and and um saying every girl in the
world should have a holding fans doesn't
mean every girl in the world should
you know all right yeah you ain't got to
be you ain't got to be doing that you're
crazy
some of these girls are finessing their
their ways
[ __ ] you can see on instagram there's
some girls on only fans that's really
getting
hit oh for sure they on there doing some
crazy [ __ ] but like
you could just go on there and just beat
you yeah i went on there and i was a
teacher
i'm damn near a professional on my [ __ ]
you know what i mean so it's like
you went the opposite route of tyga yeah
i went to opposite route but
i was finished transition you were gonna
you were gonna throw the johnson up on
there
no no no no because they yo tiger was
trending on twitter
i was like i wonder what off
god damn tiger i can't do that [ __ ] come
on yeah
like what are we doing we rapping we're
doing porn we're doing
maybe i don't see what the point of that
is
but i guess it's some publicity [ __ ] i
might it's a money play
it's money play i might [ __ ] around i
feel like tiger's low-key you know
if there was a such thing as only fans
pimping he started his little two-raw
agency
that's what nick that's what [ __ ] do
though like he's not the first to do
that [ __ ] do that bro like i got
only fantastic do that yeah it's real
like so what goes behind that if you got
friends who do it like is it
i mean [ __ ] might just they might just
find a few girls
you know they look good a lot
film video like look i can help get your
only fans popping but you gotta give me
a yeah you
you sign them up put them on
promote they only fans well won't move
you know what i'm saying
that's how i go damn that's like this
space age pimping shout out to 8 ball
and mjg that's crazy
he's illegal legal pick okay it's
illegal that [ __ ] is crazy
yeah um go like you were saying you're
like a teacher on your and i think that
you're a very smart dude um i feel like
you've navigated
uh you know fame in in a in a way that
not a lot of people in your position
have i feel like
you know you've had your little like
youtube spats with people and [ __ ] but i
feel like as far as just like being
overly goofy and
and like you know i feel like you have
never really been the butt of many jokes
a lot of times people who come up the
way you came up it's like easy
yeah i feel like jake paul these guys
are like they're kind of like
you know they're goofy you know what i'm
saying i feel like you've navigated the
fame
uh in a very mature way man and you
continue to kind of level up like what
is kind of like your secret sauce is to
to stay level-headed like that and you
know to kind of stay out the way as much
as possible
what you mean like which is i mean
obviously you've had public
relationships and [ __ ] i just mean like
i don't think i ever he really hear you
getting into any [ __ ]
yeah like most people there's always
some antics or some like
some drug [ __ ] or like whatever it is i
feel like you're a very level-headed
smart dude
yeah man i was valedictorian in high
school i don't know if anybody ever told
you that
valedictorian i think you might have
told us that in the last interview we
did
i did you might have i don't tell nobody
so you were the valedictorian i was
valedictorian in high school
yeah so i'm very smart dude you know
i don't i'm cool with everybody
everybody that meet me if
if a [ __ ] beefing with me it's because
he haven't actually met me
you know what i mean like i'm cool as
hell i'll just be chilling you know what
i mean so it's like
for me to have for a [ __ ] to have
problems with me they're reaching
so it's like you know i rarely get into
[ __ ] like that
and you've never really had like any
like you're not like a big drug dude
like anything like you never like had
the pill issues you know i feel like
everybody in l.a was [ __ ]
zombies in like 2018 for a while there
but i'm scared of that [ __ ] i just got
started smoking weed
damn near barely barely by early
yeah it's crazy man the weed is a
gateway drug so i'm trying to are we
sure about that
yeah that's that's i mean that's what
they told you in the 80s i don't know
you think weed's a gateway drug i think
it is
are you afraid you're gonna start
[ __ ] shooting heroin
bro it's weird but i'm saying i swear no
weird [ __ ]
like [ __ ] just been coming at me like
i've been hearing
everybody i've been around been talking
about mushrooms and [ __ ] well mushrooms
not a drug either you could do mushrooms
no i can't don't tell me that no no
mushrooms is not uh tell me that because
then if i start
no no no this [ __ ] is gonna be your
fault nah but it's not bad mushrooms is
a uh
it's a spiritual thing it's like a like
it's almost like
therapy now like mushrooms aren't like
so what's gonna happen if i eat that
[ __ ] well first of all you should be in
a place where you're comfortable
that's why [ __ ] keep telling me you
should be around some people that you
[ __ ] with
exactly and it's not addicting
so it's not like it's not huge or you
eat mushrooms i have before
it's not uh something that um you uh you
need to worry about like
oh man i'm doing drugs now nah it's not
that bro it's it's probably less of a
drug than wheat is
really yeah you go on a deep trip
and you might figure some [ __ ] out about
yourself man and then you come back on
the other side and this would go
cool mike tyson
uh is a a very big proponent [ __ ]
doesn't sound real though like it sounds
like a fantasy or something well
you know they say that it unlocks parts
of your brain and it kind of you know
it's almost like uh it just makes you
they call it like you know an ego killer
most
most um psychedelics are supposed to
kind of
kill your ego right so maybe maybe
there's something going on in your life
or there's something you can't get over
that you might not even remember or it
might even like
be a subconscious thing that's like on
you and then you
you tap in and you kind of work [ __ ] out
when you're uh
so you're saying it helps yeah a lot of
people man
whether it's mushrooms or dmt or
ayahuasca
that [ __ ] like i've had people like you
know i got a good friend of mine
who was a coke addict alcoholic
[ __ ] womanizer he did ayahuasca which
is
similar it's much more intense it's like
a tea that you drink
and uh he went and did it with a shaman
and came out on the other side and
hasn't touched a drug hasn't gambled
hasn't done nothing
he's like dude it was like 30 years
worth of therapy
in like six hours now that's different
than mushrooms but
i think the idea is kind of the same
there's levels to the psychedelic thing
but mushrooms you should try them
for sure if you want i get you a
mushroom chocolate chocolate bar
mushroom chocolate bar put you on i'm
gonna just smoke weed for a little bit
yeah just take take take a little eat
the mushrooms to the face man and just
you know
call off call off for six people like
you it's people like you
see that's but that ain't got nothing to
do with weed being a gateway drug
mushroom's not a drug though it
literally comes from the earth you just
eat it
where do we come from the earth exactly
but you said it's a drug
yeah i said i said it's more of a dr i
think it's more of a drug than mushrooms
i don't know lorac what do you think
similar it's different in a sense like
you be eating mushrooms
we you can smoke every day
nah you shouldn't do you should do it
so you feel like mushrooms helped you
how how did he help you
this is crazy to me bro
i guess understand parts of yourself
that you don't you can't normally access
what the [ __ ] yeah this is some crazy
[ __ ] though it makes you feel small
it makes you realize how small you
really are
yeah you should try it man i'll buy
listen i got a guy who got the mushroom
chocolate bars
oh oh billy's actually yeah he bought
like seven
bars yesterday yeah i got you bro no but
you gotta you know you gotta just you
know be with the be at your house or go
out to like joshua trees so you eat a
chocolate bar and that [ __ ] get you
you shouldn't eat the whole chocolate
bar you should eat about half
maybe three pieces and then just relax
bro and just let it let it let it work
its way into your head man
yeah that just sounds scary i'm gonna
buy this man we gonna get i'm not ready
for it we get him a chocolate bar
i'm not ready for it i'm cool man i'm
just gonna might change your life
smoke my little prerogative hey there
you go smoke your pre-rolls man
um outside of the drug conversation uh
no
let's talk about some of the game you
know because i feel like you do have the
internet figured out you've had a very
successful uh
career uh in the public eye what are
some things you think that like people
are
like with some misconceptions about kind
of
that that world that you came from and
like how like what would be some advice
you would give some upcoming content
creators because
you know people that want to cross over
or well no no i'm talking like just
getting into
like both of my sons like my son's a fan
of yours right um
but like both of my kids they want to
grow up and be youtubers
yeah and now i hate i know you hate that
term
and we'll get to that too what the why
work yeah the y word
yeah i can't say that to around me but
what i'm saying is like you know you you
you figured that [ __ ] out you've kind of
you know
figured it out what would be some advice
you would give some kids watching right
now who's like yo
i want to do that that's what i want to
do when i when i get older
okay so i mean it's really
like this might sound like cliche or
whatever but
it's literally just being consistent
like i'm talking about
2017 i was uploading every
day i'm talking about if you go if you
can if you can put
january first yeah december 31st
2017 it's gonna say at least 500 videos
wow i'm talking about
eating 19 crazy then 2018 after that
it's like i had residual income oh
oh [ __ ] like i'm blowing three videos a
day so
2018 i'm just ch that was a breeze
damn so it's really just the consistency
because this is do you remember
in 2017 before you became that
consistent like do you remember
like the jump in um subscribers you had
uh yeah i mean i blew up after i
dropped out of college now i blew up i
got with
i had an ex back in the past and i did
like this little
cheating prank on her and it blew up and
then i started vlogging from there
that blew up and then i went back
sophomore year in college and i was
making so much cheese i just dropped out
and moved out here
and you was editing your own videos oh
my [ __ ] damn
i got to edit it for a little bit but i
didn't like it because it made me more
lazy
so i mean it was days i upload seven
videos in one day
i ain't talking about like no reactions
i'm talking about seven
ten minute plus vlogs [ __ ] i'm talking
about not
eating jesus christ but i was making six
figures a month
like going crazy
and now with uh you know you're
transitioning
seems to be as like a full-time artist
now
how often do you still like oh that's my
whole life so you don't engage in that
kind of [ __ ] like
you know like obviously you're still
tapped in on your youtube with your fans
because they said yeah yeah i love my
supporters but as far as like my family
your focus is
totally fully made yeah 100 artists man
come on
yo you got to write me listen man i i
just i we i'll be having this discussion
with a lot of people because i remember
being in here when he was recording once
and i was like
oh this fool's actually like writing his
own [ __ ] and it's dope like
at the end of the day like i've also
been in here with youtubers
who are [ __ ] horrible who
need writers or they they really just
need to do some other [ __ ]
yeah because the music ain't for them
but you like bro your [ __ ] is
i've heard a lot of your unreleased [ __ ]
and it's very very good man so
props to you for for for figuring that
out um
i got some [ __ ] coming but you
definitely are very um
you take offense to people calling you a
youtuber turned rapper right
or to kind of putting that youtube
rapper like that
i know there was like a little uh you
gotta stop saying that around me man
that's what i'm saying so you know
i i appreciate why i offend you because
you're like yo look i'm really an artist
yeah um but but is it is it kind of
unfair to get mad at people if they say
that
because i know you kind of had a little
spat with adam 22 at least
you're not a fan of adam 22. nah i'm i
think adam 22 is just he knows
the position he knows his his power
so he feel like he could just say
whatever but in person nick cool as hell
no he's a great different he get on the
internet he talks so much [ __ ] in person
what's up bro so it's like [ __ ] just go
here but the youtube rapper title is
something that you do not [ __ ] with
i mean to be honest i really don't give
a [ __ ] i'll just be meme in myself like
i just missed
saying i'm a rapper very right that's
just one of the things i've been saying
now like
it's just a part of my
um what you call it
i don't know strategy i guess yeah look
man like you said you got the
you got this [ __ ] figured out for better
or worse yeah i mean [ __ ] already knew
our
[ __ ] knew i been hard that's the thing
everybody knew i been
hard it was just about for me it's
literally just association
so when somebody see me with another
that's why i knew moon walking was going
to blow up i'm like
damn this [ __ ] blew and this [ __ ] blue
face snapped on that [ __ ]
he was on beat he was going bonkers
yeah he had to be nudged or nothing that
was straight he was on beat yeah
took him like 20 minutes ran through
that [ __ ] right so i'm like okay
back this thing he's like i shoot the
video i'm like [ __ ] back
because you know coming off of youtube
as a as an artist
they probably would look at somebody
like me coming off of youtube it's like
i don't really want to associate with
that [ __ ] like that because because i
don't want to be in that lane
there's a stigma that comes from that
yeah so blueface showed me love and [ __ ]
so i was like back you know what i mean
real [ __ ] whoop
so we shot the video about bob and it
was just
i already knew it was gonna blow up
right it was just about
who was gonna be the person to give me
that shot
you know what i mean do you remember uh
when you first found out the song was on
rap caviar because that's kind of like
that's like that that yeah that's that
career changer that that's like at the
top
it was like the top of rap caviar that's
that was it right there wrap caviar
shout out to them [ __ ]
yeah like when you shout out spiders do
you remember when you found out that it
was on it because you know it wasn't
like it was just on there i got my
notification
this [ __ ] was like at the top she went
to gmail came straight to my gmail
like oh [ __ ] we might have something
here yeah can i drink this yeah
of course man i got a cotton mouth man
get your water buddy yeah no i think uh
you know congrats man um i know this is
gonna come out after the other remix is
out so you got yg on the
remix 2.0 remix 2.0 my dog yg
what was that a organic thing yeah how
did that
i'll be right i'm just cool with
everybody man i'll just be around you'll
be playing basketball with everybody
that's for damn sure
yeah i do that's how me and blueface got
cool
okay i was hooping i pulled up to la
fitness
he told me pull up and hoot polo g was
there too so us three we was hooping
and then he was like you trying to go
with me to san diego
to perform at these schools and then i
went with him to san diego and he was
going to school he was late
it's in san diego yeah you i always see
you hooping uh with
the who's who uh of hip-hop uh
who's the best basketball player in in
that you've played with
artist-wise um
that's a good question man
it's a great question i mean you know
you played with all these cats who
really who's really with with
i mean i don't lose often that's the
thing i'm not talking about yourself
at all so yeah i mean okay it's putting
yourself aside
okay putting me aside yeah cause i'm the
best
you think you're the best yeah i'm the
best better than cuevo
yeah so if you put me to the side i
never played quavo though cueva was good
did you play chris brown i play with
chris brown and and
you think you're better than chris brown
chris brown is pretty good i think
i think chris brown is good at
everything he's pretty good he's pretty
good
like he'd be good at like whatever i
just feel like when i'm on the court
it's not i don't see look i'm not a
dribbler
i'm not no you just spectacular passer
you're just shooting
but i'm strong as hell i'ma hit that
shot
if you let me make that [ __ ] i'ma keep
making that [ __ ] and if you let me back
you down you're like jj reddick
i'm like you're staying in the corner a
lot of people just shy shoot the three
you're like hip hop
jj reddy no a lot of people compare me
to steph curry
with a little bit of dwayne wade jesus
yeah that's kind of random
steph curry shout out dwayne wade um
yeah you never gave me your answer
though who was the best in your opinion
um
outside of yourself obviously i played
uh black boy jb
he was pretty cool really he was all
right he was mid-level
but i give it to him he like he beat me
kind of sort of kind of
i might have recorded it is it oh it was
recorded
yeah i uploaded it oh you i haven't seen
it so blackboard jb got
he beat you he just he just was just
like he had a lot of energy
and i didn't expect him to and plus my
brother bet
500 dollars on me so he put a lot of
pressure on me so i'm like damn i got it
so you guys went under 500 yeah i got to
win my brother money and [ __ ]
but he was he he was going to get that
fire honey he didn't want to pay the 500
but it wasn't my 500
so i didn't care as much as he cared you
know what i'm saying i got you
so he went way harder than i did but we
rematched it
um what are your thoughts on uh
the pivot that jake paul
and his brother have done in the
fighting i think it's amazing i think
it's incredible
legendary it is they're my legendary
people right there
yo we're uh breaking down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video
to tell you all about our sponsors odd
socks all right listen man
uh odd socks official.com what the [ __ ]
was that bro
uh it was like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair
floating in air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20 off if you use that
keyword they got south park
license they got some ghostbusters pimp
c
mike tyson really the one that i really
care about is they got that wwe license
you can get these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable
they're probably the most comfortable
socks
actually not probably definitively the
most comfortable socks i've ever put on
my feet
yes all right and that goes for all
types of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time is on the way
use the keyword boulet kev 20 off
oddsoxofficial.com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go when jake paul ran up on um
conor mcgregor gregor's boy the other
day in the back of the truck
throwing [ __ ] at him i was like this kid
is a genius
he's going to make conor mcgregor fight
him because nobody ever would have
thought that that would happen but i
feel like it has to happen now
this dude's trolling him so hard he's
he's they're they're doing great work
would you fight
if if the bag was right would you go and
get in the ring yes
if the bag is right if i'm do you know
how much money they made
yes that i don't know i don't know how
much money they made because i know
me on the undercard i want somebody to
put me on under cardboard that's
i'm witty i'm definitely would you take
the jake paul fade though
yeah for the bag yeah you'd be the ender
you'd definitely be the underdog
there ain't nothing wrong with that i
used cc i used to box in four years
okay so i don't know you can actually
fight yeah i can actually fight i'm like
naked i get in there yeah nate robinson
just didn't know how to box
yeah that was rough to watch but boxing
at the end of the day boxing is a sport
you know what i mean it's just
a strategy it's not but jake paul is
obviously getting better yeah of course
he's been boxing for three years
it's a lot of experience that come with
that so i think when you mix like his
i kind of think yeah he might beat
connor no
no no no no come on man no cap come on
man
his brother's gonna get washed i guess i
mean come on no man you
never know listen i don't know if you
know but nate robinson is
this [ __ ] is dunking at five six he's a
tiny man
and he put him to sleep yeah but he's
bro that's that
i get what you said but it's just like
jake you can't discredit jake paul he's
not like a scrawny like
little dude when that fight started you
did not think
jake paul was gonna sleep that [ __ ]
like that i won money
i bet on jake paul i want to tell you
about the channel
but you ain't think he was going to
sleep is it i thought it was going to be
i actually
thought it was going to be ugly
because if you look at them next to each
other you're like damn nate robinson so
small
bro and like this kid you know has been
fighting he trained with shane mosley
and
like you know those guys pretty well the
paws yeah they're cool as [ __ ]
you know cool yeah i feel like they they
probably have a bit of a you know
there's probably you know everybody's
got misconceptions about them
yeah no i don't think it's cool as hell
smart people water smart
who are the um like like
is there somebody who kind of inspires
you
in that space to like level up the
hustle to level up like
what you're doing because i feel like
with this music thing there's just a
whole nother stream of revenue that's
about to get knocked down for you
and you've been doing music for a few
years now obviously but to really like
catch one is like different but like who
some people
not necessarily just on the youtube side
just in general in the music industry in
the entertainment industry that kind of
inspire your hustle man
i would say i want to be like
in like the next five years i want to be
like a ditty
okay you know what i mean i'm trying to
have like you're trying to do everything
i'm trying to do everything my own
liquor and
all types of crazy [ __ ] like i'm always
bro i'm doing so much
all 10 fingers touching something yeah
what all you have going on obviously we
know
know about the music we know about your
youtube [ __ ] but like what all what else
do you have your hands in
you know any only fans pimping i made a
lot of money on only fans in a very
short amount of time i bet you did
a lot but i can't tell you i'll tell you
off camera without
it ain't nothing illegal okay but i
would tell you off camera but any any
sort of crypto
you're [ __ ] with yeah i just ate
because bitcoin just hit 22 000
i ate i'm eating right now i'm still i'm
still in there
do you remember when you bought bitcoin
like how much it was three
years i'm not up up like everybody else
like i should be right because i bought
it when it was 14 000
in like 2017 like a dummy i didn't know
what i was doing
but i lost it all it went down right but
i never
never sold so you went all the way back
up no i'm
up you might i think you should sell now
i think he's gonna dip again
so now just rebuy i don't know what do
you think eric rock bitcoin boy
should he sell now that [ __ ] is
going to hit
30. that's [ __ ] you're over you're
giving mushroom advice you [ __ ]
that [ __ ] it's gonna hit like 30. [ __ ]
if it
it's gonna keep going bro it might
we'll see we'll see god damn it
um is there gonna be an album i got a
project coming out next year
next year well i mean [ __ ] where it's
like december we're dropping something
on the 25th surprise
a surprise like song project to be
determined
to be determined oh but next year is my
project project me and og parker oh
whole project with og parker
old project oh [ __ ] it's crazy that's
fire
and it's a lot of features lots of
features
who's your um because you have already
kind of worked with a lot of artists
right so like who's like uh
who you kind of feel like you got the
best chemistry with
well like people that i'm just just just
people you've worked with that are
you know other artists because you you
you have worked with a lot of artists
already the people that we know about
and i'm sure a bunch more we don't know
about but like
who do you think you got the best
chemistry with in studio so far
i mean everybody really
i mean that's a [ __ ] that's a yeah
but i mean they like
oh this is my better friend like i don't
know what she's like i feel like that
i'm not somebody who's a better friend i
mean like you know
first of all not everyone's getting in
the studio i'm sure there's been some
mp3 back and forth it is but i mean like
people you've actually been in the lab
with like
yo that was real easy to pull off like
we like there was a vibe there like
uh
2k baby 2k baby yeah i need cools but
that's my [ __ ]
you know it's i i know who he is and
i've heard of him obviously but i've
never listened to his music
hard at the time um
tyler yahweh yeah yeah tyler tyler's
fire i've known tyler since he was uh
[ __ ] he was in a group called swamp
posse when i lived in florida and he was
he's from orlando and i lived in tampa
good kid man
yeah tyler yawa good guy ty dolla sign
coos [ __ ]
aren't you on the tyler remix yeah i did
the stun on you remix
yeah which is kind of dope that kind of
tells you because usually you know the
hottest dudes got to get on the remixes
of these records so
well that was that's what i'm saying no
i'm saying that like i kind of
certified you like make you like you
know like yeah like you know
this music game i'm like damn yeah yeah
that was kind of random i was just
playing 2k
yeah how was uh like dame lillard is a
guy he's a dude pretty cool
regular everybody's just regular yeah
everybody just beat
damian lillard definitely the probably
the greatest um
rapping basketball player of all time
yeah shaq was whatever
kobe was not good at rapping
ai's [ __ ] was kind of weak jason kidd
tried to rap
cedric zavala's tried to rap there's
some bad
who else has been trying oh what's his
name
jared jackson jr from the grizzlies
recorded some [ __ ] here it was horrible
good guy though good guy nonetheless um
all right so look
hey this actually might come out after
christmas
so this is going to come out after
christmas so plug whatever's supposed to
come out on christmas
uh zooted mixtape the mixtape's called
zooted
well i have an independent label okay is
that called
music zooted music yes i have three
artists
so so this is like a compilation yeah
it's like it's like compilation between
all of us
so that's coming out hard [ __ ] though
all hardships
zooted entertainment zooted music zooted
music
wow that word suited zooed it we've
we've had this discussion about zooted
like literally an hour before you got
here yes
look it up man no no we're aware of the
word it's just he tried to tell me it
came from florida you said it came from
florida i was like bro there's no way
where the [ __ ] came from i was just
saying a lot and then i
thought about the definition in my head
and it's just to go
up whether you're high yeah what's your
um
just for to make everyone feel really
bad what's the most money you've ever
made on youtube in a single month
see i got to talk to you after but i'ma
tell you
the most i made was like truthfully
people probably think i made way more i
probably did
because i got like three fourths it was
like the way they changed up the some of
the youtube programming and yeah but but
but the most you ever got like off of
them
the most that i can say
just off one channel i would say 150.
hey man 150 has a lot 150 000 in a month
yeah
but it it's [ __ ] that make
what's the little kids what's the little
kid's name that opens ryan's toy review
i don't even want to know what his [ __ ]
i feel like he's probably making like
1.5 million million damn
yeah but at that when you at that point
of making that much money this [ __ ] is
not even exciting no more it's not like
it becomes regular believe it or not
it's like yes between them and some of
these makeup artists my girl be watching
all these damn makeup artists bros
you know kylie jenner made 570 million
this year often made off of makeup
who the [ __ ] is giving her that much
money that is
crazy i saw that she was the highest
paid like forbes highest paid celebrity
or whatever
yeah i'm finna start selling makeup what
the [ __ ] yeah because otherwise like
what is what else is she giving to the
marketplace besides makeup
she's just genius she's fighting makeup
she's just a genius these people are
really smart
yeah so everybody that's on that list is
just smart that's all it is
because there's so much money out here
don't make no sense you gotta pay taxes
if you
know the right [ __ ] do you know the
right [ __ ]
i gotta talk to you after this video
yeah yo well listen
give us a give it give before we wrap
this up because a lot of people man like
look taxes is coming
give some uh some real basic we always
wonder how rich people always don't pay
taxes
can you give us kind of some basic game
on the on taxes like that you could kind
of like
i mean a little basic game for me just
you live in california
i live here the state tax is [ __ ]
bonkers yeah
you know it is what it is but i just
know that
i just i'm just able to write off a lot
of [ __ ] that's for me because i record
everything
that's my cheat code so like what can
you say it's for a video
like i'm writing off this this jewelry
i'm about to go spend 20 000 on the
chain but i'm gonna title the video
i spent 20 000 on the chain and then
they'd be like
where the [ __ ] does 20 000 come from and
then you say look this look at the
videos
i literally had to buy it for the video
it's called i suppose entertainment
that's smart it's investing reinvesting
in myself i like that
that's actually a nice little gym yes
right now
yo everybody go monetize the youtube
account
right go go start at youtube and when
black friday comes
like rappers can do it too i spent 400
on a tv
right just put it on the internet even
if it has seven views
you could be like yo that was that black
friday tv i wrote that [ __ ] off because
i got the youtube video
i'm trying to pop off as this content in
this content space
take a picture of that [ __ ] wow
i'm gonna start a whole youtube channel
and no one even knows about where i'm
only posting stuff like
i spent 78 dollars on groceries at robs
and here's the video so i'm writing off
my groceries
yeah whoa my god this is private zero
views
you're very smart show them the screen
shot this guy got the game yo go to his
only fans he's not showing his johnson
he's giving you game
yeah yeah he's not gonna you're not
tagging us yet man
not yet you got a lot of kids that are
probably [ __ ] with you still too or
they're kind of like growing up with you
growing up so it's like the [ __ ]
getting old enough so sooner or later
i'm gonna have to
drop one well what's your what's your uh
you know uh you're obviously single
yeah single out here you know
getting it popping no you sliding in dms
nope that was a hesitation no i'm not
i'm never sliding the dmc i'm protecting
my energy
that's fair because they're going to go
very very far in life and i can't just
bring anybody with me
hey man not everybody can make the cut
shout out to ruby robes you know what i
mean
anyway uh appreciate you for coming
through
go support uh the zooted uh compilation
yeah shout out your three artists autumn
corinne
pay way to yo baby rit boom yeah
going up go support moonwalking and
calabasas the remix and the remix to the
remix video coming with yg
remix it's fire matter of fact i just
got it i'm gonna watch it let's go
boom boo lay cat podcast ddg